So let's continue our discussion of ways in
which Donald Trump may try to subvert or challenge
the will of the people in November of 2020
to get himself reelected.
Let's talk about Michigan.
Michigan has been a big target of Donald Trump's
ire.
Michigan has been looking at vote by mail.
They decided they are going to be sending
absentee ballot applications to every voter.
Now, I want to remember let's not forget that
Michigan is not sending an absentee ballot
to everyone.
Michigan is sending an application for an
absentee ballot to anybody who wants one.
Trump tried to argue on Twitter last week
that by sending a ballot to everybody, Michigan
is doing something wrong.
Remember that Michigan is sending an application
to everybody.
And in Michigan, the lieutenant governor,
Garland Gilchrist, the second said to MSNBC
that he believes Trump realizes he's likely
to lose Michigan in November.
And so he is kind of stirring up all of this
controversy over vote by mail in order to
create a pretext to challenge the results
in Michigan.
The lieutenant governor recently said in an
interview with MSNBC, quote, I think that
the president wants to set us up so that there
can be a conversation about the legitimacy
of an election that he is looking to lose.
That is a really unfortunate thing.
That's not how we do democracy here in the
United States.
And we need to be ready to respond to that
forcefully.
So you don't need to think too hard to realize
there is a very good chance Trump is going
to call election results into question in
2020 in the November 2020 election.
Trump won in 2016 and he still says it was
rigged.
So understand, for three years, Donald Trump
has been attacking the trustworthiness of
an election that he won.
So, of course, he's going to challenge the
results.
If he loses in November.
Now, whether he'll get away with it, we'll
discuss in a moment.
In terms of Michigan, Trump won Michigan.
It was really close.
Trump won Michigan by about 11000 votes over
Hillary Clinton.
That was zero point three percent in terms
of a margin of victory.
Right now, Trump is losing to Biden in Michigan.
In the last four polls, Trump is down by three,
four, seven and eight.
OK, the way to prevent Trump from credibly
arguing that the Michigan results are bogus
is to defeat him in a landslide, to defeat
Trump so overwhelmingly in Michigan that there
is no credible way for him to say it was rigged.
Then 10000 votes, 15000 votes were the difference
maker.
They are going to bring out every trick they
can.
And Michigan is very likely to be a primary
target, which is why Donald Trump keeps talking
about Michigan all the time.
Now, it's also always personal for Donald
Trump.
Part of Donald Trump's focus on Michigan is
that he's been feuding with Gretchen Whitmer,
who's been the Democratic Michigan governor
overseeing the Corona virus response.
And this is a surefire way for Donald Trump
to attack you.
She has been standing her ground against Donald
Trump when it comes to Corona virus and policy.
Her polling is much better than Trump's in
terms of corona virus handling.
So that makes Trump absolutely furious.
Now, let's talk about whether this will work.
I've said before, if Trump loses, he will
likely claim it was rigged, but he will leave.
It's not likely to be what we would call a
peaceful transition of power.
So when you look back at the Bush handoff
to Barack Obama, when you look at the Obama
handoff to Donald Trump, we had what we would
call a peaceful transition of power.
The outgoing president inviting the incoming
president to a White House visit, even though
these were hard fought political battles.
We checked every single box for what we call
a respectful, proper, peaceful transition
of power.
I would expect Trump to continue being the
petulant child that he's proven himself to
be, refusing to welcome Joe Biden to the White
House, refusing to do these perfunctory things
that outgoing.
Presidents do, and quite frankly, I don't
care.
I don't want to get ahead of myself.
If Biden wins, if Biden wins.
The only thing that will matter is that Joe
Biden won.
Trump can do whatever he wants as long as
he leaves and we can get back to something
more normal.
Now, let me throw out one other thing I've
been thinking about.
If Donald Trump loses and claims that it was
rigged and still ends up leaving, it could
be a good thing for the country.
And what I mean by that is Donald Trump has
successfully ignored, flouted, not flaunted,
flouted checks and balances, ignored separations
of power, emoluments, attacking the media,
accusing TV hosts of murder.
Justice Department deciding, hey, we're not
going to prosecute someone.
Michael Flynn, who's already pleaded guilty.
It might actually be reassuring for the United
States to see Trump argue, I really won, I
really won, I really won and still be forced
out because it would reassure us that at least
some of our institutions are still working,
seeing that an institution still works.
Seeing that a check and balance still functions.
Seeing Trump try to say it was rigged but
still having to leave could be exactly the
reassurance we need that we will start to
get back to something approximating a more
normal government.
It's a thought.
And in the end, all that matters is that he
does leave.
That's all that really matters
in
the end.